the Senate Judiciary Committee is
holding hearings this week on the
nomination of Judge Neal gorvich to the
US Supreme Court Corphish is a federal
judge with admirers across the political
spectrum but his news on several crucial
constitutional issues remain unclear
here are three question I'd like to hear
judge Gorsuch address for the Senate
Judiciary Committee this week the
Supreme Court has upheld the power of
the federal government to prosecute
cannabis users in California under
Congress's authority to regulate
interstate commerce if the medical
marijuana that was the focus of that
2005 ruling was both grown and consumed
only in California I'd like to hear
judge Gorsuch explain his views on the
limits of federal power does Congress
have the authority to ban a local
activity that's illegal under state law
the federal courts are currently hearing
arguments about the constitutionality
president Trump's ban of travelers from
a handful of majority Muslim countries
according to the trump administration
the federal courts have no business
second-guessing the President's
authority on an issue that affects
national security I'd like to know if
judge Gorsuch agrees that the
president's executive orders are beyond
the reach of judicial review how
deferential must the federal courts be
to the commander-in-chief the
Constitution lists a number of
individual rights such as free speech
and the right to keep their arm but it
also refers to write that aren't
explicitly mentioned for example the
Supreme Court has protected the right to
privacy right as parents to send their
children to private schools and the
right to gay marriage none of these
rights are mentioned anywhere in the
text of the Constitution his 2006 book
George Gorsuch was critical of reading
the Constitution in this way he wrote
that the Due Process Clause of the
Fourteenth Amendment has been stretched
beyond recognition in the name of
defending on Britain right I'd like to
know what George gorvich thinks the same
is true of the ninth amendment to the
privileges or immunities Clause both of
which refer to unwritten rights does he
think the Constitution protects any
rights that are
what we mention the American people
deserve to hear what church course which
has to say another fundamental conflict
issues given the many unanswered
questions about his jurisprudence you
could explain himself fully this week
and it's complimentary
[Music]